hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the alakan fried
liver trap so the icon starts out with
e4
knight to f6 here pawn pushes forward to
attack the knight knight to d5 usually
don't just want to come back here to
g8 here pawn to d4
centralizing the pawns defending this
pawn here on e5
and then d6 this attacks this center
control that white has also opens up for
the light square bishop to get involved
into the game and white can either play
pawn to
c4 or the most popular move is just
knight to
f3 normal development move controlling
these central pawns with the knight and
black can either play the bishop down
here to g4 one of the reasons you play
d6 is to get your light square bishop
involved into the game or the second
most popular move is to play pawn to g6
preparing to fee and cater the bishop
here to
g7 now the name from frye liver comes in
very similar to if you've watched the
fried liver attack and that is
white playing the move knight to g5
saying yes i'm gonna go ahead and attack
the square here on f7 which early on is
one of the weakest squares for black
because it's only defended by the black
king and say hey i may even sacrifice
this knight here because i'm going to
have a very strong attack
even though i'm going to be down in
material so knight 2 g5 attacking the
pawn right here and black has a few
options as far as how they can continue
you know if they play bishop here to
g7 continue their normal thought process
then white has queen two f3
this is attacking queen up here taking
on f7 you could take with your knight
here on f7 attacking both the queen and
the rook here you're also attacking this
knight here on
d5 so lots of different ways that white
can attack here one of the things that
black could try to do is to play the
move pawn to h6 it is kind of breaking
up their
structure here on the king side as far
as the pawn protection but if they kind
of look at they can already recognize
that things are starting to blow up
anyway so they may just want to get this
knight out of here but this is exactly
what white wants to happen and white's
going to play the move knight takes here
on f7
as we discussed earlier black usually
wants to go ahead and take with their
king here on f7 if not we are forking
the queen and the rook here usually
don't just want to give us more material
here so king takes here on f7 and then
white plays the move queen to f3 this is
attacking the king so in check and also
attacking this knight here on
d5 now the best move from black is to
just play knight to f6 which looks kind
of weird because the pawn here on e5
can just take it and absolutely can but
that's the best move from black it's
it's very difficult i think to find
because after the pawn takes then we're
playing bishop here to c4 getting more
material involved into the game maybe
they play king to g7 uh now knight to c3
you can see white's getting all their
material involved this king is
completely exposed this rook over here
on a8 is not going to be doing anything
this bishop here on f8 is completely
blocked in
and white can just really start to pound
their opponent they can castle on the
queen's head at some point just throw
everything at the king side it's gonna
be very difficult for black to hold on
to this but that's really the best way
that black has to defend this and so i
think that one's going to be very
difficult for them to find
now the other option is for black to try
to hold on to this knight maybe
something like king 2 e6 just says yeah
i'm going to get out of the check and
i'm also going to try to protect this
knight here on
d5
now white has the move pawn to
c4 attacking this knight now how does
black continue from here well
it's actually correct to just still play
that knight to f6 but this is still
pretty awkward and i think it's very
difficult for black to find because
we're just going to go ahead and take
that knight here on f6 after the pawn
takes then we play bishop here to
d3 preparing to castle on the king side
you can see all the threats that we have
here the king's in the center of the
board even blocking off some of the
material here with the light square
bishop the queen can't get involved the
stark square bishop can't get involved
neither the rooks are involved and so
white can really just develop more
material and then start to push and they
always have moves like queen two d5 for
check they can always push forward with
the pawns here get their other bishop
involved into the game knight c3 adds a
lot of pressure as well so this is going
to be pretty tough for them to deal with
but there's another trap they could fall
into and that is if they play the move
knight to
b4 if they think that they're in harm's
way knight to b4 gets out of harm's way
and it also
prepares an attack here on knight to c2
and this is check and it's also forking
this rook here on a1
if black does play this and fall into
the trap this is going to be a quick
checkmate no way to stop it after the
move pawn to
d5 check if you look at it black can't
take here on e5 because just queen to f4
that's going to be checkmate the king
can't come to the ephile just because
the queen is defending that and so if
the king comes back here to d7 well
pawnee six king comes back here and
that's gonna be checkmate as well and if
they try to just take this pawn here
with their knight if they recognize hey
i should just give back this knight
which they should have done a long time
ago then white can go ahead and take
here on d5 after the king takes here on
e5 uh then a little bit different move
uh than before but now we're gonna be
playing the move pawn to b4 preparing to
play the move bishop here to b2 and
there's no way to really stop this you
know bishop here to
f5 as an example but then just bishop
here to
b2 and you can see this is checkmate
kind of a weird checkmate with king in
the center of the board and really just
the the bishop giving the check but the
pawn here blocking off being protected
by the queen
and just defending all of the squares
that black would want to go to now black
could delay this a little bit by playing
the move knight to c6 only reason they
would do that is the knight can now come
to d4 to protect from the check if this
is the case why it's going to change it
up just slightly and they're going to
play the move
queen 2 f4 check
then king over here takes on d5 but then
the move bishop here to c4 and this is
going to be checkmate so no way to stop
it uh from black once they play that
move knight to
b4 uh
preparing to come down and fork our king
they're not going to have that chance
after we play d5 it is going to be
checkmate so that is the alekhine fried
liver
always be thinking of ways if you come
back to the beginning of this how you
can play your knights here to
g5 because threatening this square here
on f7
many times the exchange is going to be
worth it because you can start to launch
a very very powerful attack on your
opponent this shows that the fried liver
can be effective even in the alekhine
defense which many times is known to be
very very solid from black once you
expose that king it is off to the races
so thank you guys so much for watching
this video i know many of you really
love these traps give you a different
perspective on how to think about chess
and some nuances around when someone
plays in a certain way how you can start
to attack your opponents thank you guys
for watching the video i'll see you guys
next time
you